[Musique]
alors en autre style de guirlande pour
décorer la maison vous avez l'orange
alors vous connaissez sûrement le clou
de girofle piqué moi je trouve que les
clous de girofle c'est quand même des
boutons de fleurs c'est un peu dommage
mais bon s'ils sont un peu vieux ça peut
être pas mal moi je coupe l'orange en
petite tranche je vous ai préparé à
l'avance
voilà pas trop épaisse un demi
centimètre c'est parfait
je coupe mes tranches
je prends du fil et une aiguille bon
j'ai choisi un beau jaune la même
couleur que l'orange et puis je peux
faire ça avec plein d'agrumes du citron
jaune du citron vert même du
pamplemousse si je veux
j'enfile mon fil hein et je construis
des guirlandes comme ça voilà que je
vais accrocher sur la fenêtre ou sur la
porte qui peut être autour de la de la
couronne de Noël